rejoignez-moi sur patreon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des courants visaux
des apérophilos un moyen simple de
soutenir mon travail tout en vous
donnant matière à penser je vous attends
sur patreon le lien est dans la
description bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui on va parler de l'art
de la guerre de
sunsu l'art de la guerre est un manuel
je devrais même dire le manuel de
référence en terme de stratégie
militaire le plus cité et le plus
commenté encore de nos jours il a été
écrit entre le 6e et le 3e siècle avant
Jésus-Christ la datation exacte et
difficile d'autant plus difficile que
son auteur sunsu est un personnage
mystérieux certains spécialistes
prétendent même qu'il n'aurait tout
simplement jamais existé ou en tout cas
qu'on a'urait pas de réelle preuve de
son existence tandis que pour d'autres
il s'agirait d'un noble originaire du
Royaume de K qui aurait étudié l'art
militaire pendant des années avant de
devenir conseiller du roi et ces
conseils auraient permis au roi de
l'époque de conquérir de nombreuses
régions du territoire de Chine puisque'à
l'époque la plupart des guerres étaient
d'ordre
interne mais que sunsu ait réellement
existé ou pas en réalité peu importe
parce que ce qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui c'est le contenu de son
livre l'art de la guerre l'art de la
guerre qui je le précise tout de suite
n'est pas un livre de philosophie mais
qu'on peut appréhender de manière
philosophique l'art de la guerre c'est
un rapport au conflit c'est un rapport à
l'efficacité et à
l'intelligence dont on peut tirer des
choses philosophiquement parlant et
c'est ce qu'on va essayer de faire tout
au long cet
épisode alors je vais commencer en vous
racontant une anecdote qu'on attribue à
sunsu une anecdote qui va nous mettre un
peu dans l'ambiance sunsu propose au roi
de lui montrer comment on dirige une
armée et pour ça il lui demande de
réunir ses 180
domestiques le roi a plusieurs
maîtresses sunsu en choisit deux et il
est nomme officier et là il leur dit qu'
à son signal elles devront se tourner
vers la droite sunsu dit à droite et les
deux maîtresses éclate de rire
elles ne prennent pas le jeu au sérieux
sunsu se tourne vers le roi et lui dit
lorsque l'ordre n'est pas exécuté c'est
qu'il n'a pas été énoncé clairement
c'est donc le général qui est en tort
ils se retournent vers les maîtresses il
leur demande si elles savent distinguer
leur droite de leur gauche la réponse
est oui il leur répète qu'à son signal
elles devront se tourner vers la droite
à droite les maîtresses éclatent de rire
à nouveau et là sunsu se retourne vers
le roi et il dit lorsque l'ordre n'est
pas exécuté alors qu'il a été énoncé
clairement ce sont les officiers qui
sont en
tort et il fait exécuter les deux
maîtresses pour de vrai
à partir de là tous les domestiques ont
joué le jeu ou plutôt ils ont compris
que ce n'était pas un jeu et ils se sont
mis à obéir comme un seul homme la
morale de cette histoire c'est qu'en
matière militaire on ne fait pas de
sentiment la pitié n'a pas sa place sur
le champ de
bataille la compassion n'a pas sa
place la seule chose qui a sa place
c'est la victoire et la victoire exige
d'être
impitoyable la première chose dont il
faut parler c'est le fait que pour sunsu
la fin justifie les moyens la fin
justifie les moyens autrement dit la
guerre est par définition
amoral ce qui compte ce n'est donc pas
la nature des moyens ce qui compte c'est
le
résultat la
victoire la victoire justifie qu'on
aille contre la morale
donc s'il faut tuer des innocents pour
ça aucun problème s'il faut mentir pour
ça aucun problème sunsu identifie l'art
de la guerre à l'art de la ruse à l'art
du mensonge et de la
manipulation quand on pense à la guerre
habituellement on pense aux armes au
fusil au missile aux bombes
ou on pense au soldats c'est-à-dire
à ceux qui manient les armes autrement
dit quand on pense à la guerre on pense
à l'exercice de la
force une armée est d'autant plus
redoutée qu'elle est matériellement
puissante bien ce que nous dit sunsu
c'est que ça marche pas comme ça on peut
pas miser uniquement sur la force c'est
important la force et Suns le dit
plusieurs fois chaque munition laissée
par l'ennemi on la récupère les
prisonniers on les garde et on les fait
travailler donc ça compte la puissance
matérielle ça compte mais ça fait pas
tout nous
dit ce n'est pas ça qui est
déterminant ce qui est déterminant c'est
la
stratégie et la stratégie c'est le plan
d'ensemble qui permet de n'utiliser la
force que dans les cas où c'est
nécessaire
mais ce n'est pas tout le temps
nécessaire on peut obtenir des résultats
bien plus efficaces sans la
force c'est ça la stratégie utiliser
toutes les données disponibles pour
vaincre en se battant le moins
possible la stratégie c'est par exemple
tout ce qui contribue à créer de la
confusion chez
l'ennemi parce que de la confusion n
l'erreur et une erreur c'est une
occasion une guerre ne se gagne pas
seulement sur nos réussites elle se
gagne également sur les erreurs de
l'adversaire parce qu'on peut construire
sur ces erreurs comme aux échecs on en
parlera tout à l'heure ou comme en box
un boxeur ne gagne pas uniquement parce
qu'il frappe le plus fort il gagne aussi
parce qu'il a su exploiter les erreurs
de son adversaire un mauvais mauvais
cadre un mauvais cardio une mauvaise
garde la garde c'est l'équivalent du
rempard donc un boxeur a tout intérêt à
faire baisser sa garde à son
adversaire parce qu'alors il peut
l'atteindre il peut lui causer des
dégâts parce que dès lors que
l'adversaire est à découvert il est
impuissant il n'y a besoin que de peu de
puissance pour vaincre un ennemi sans
défense la puissance s'effondre face à
la
ruse donc pour sunsu une guerre efficace
c'est une guerre dans laquelle on n pas
besoin de
combattre une bonne guerre c'est une
guerre dans laquelle notre victoire ne
dépend pas de notre force mais de notre
capacité de manipuler les forces
adverses dans l'imagerie occidentale
quand on pense à l'art martial chinois
on pense au code de l'honneur on pense
au sacrifice à la
vertu sauf que ça c'était avant
sunsu le combat pour la gloire le combat
héroïque le problème c'est que celui qui
combat pour la gloire va privilégier la
distinction individuelle à l'efficacité
collective celui qui combat pour la
gloire veut qu'on retienne son nom il
veut qu'on pense à lui comme un
modèle parce que c'est ça qui est beau
dans la guerre la
bravoure ce que nous dit sunsum c'est
que la guerre est une affaire trop
importante trop vitale c'est le mot
qu'il emploie pour y introduire des
considérations
esthétiques les guerriers ne sont pas là
pour laisser leur nom dans l'histoire
ils sont là pour
gagner ce qui doit primé dans la guerre
c'est
l'efficacité et l'efficacité ne prend
pas le
sacrifice s'il y a eu sacrifice c'est
qu'il y a eu erreur c'est qu'on a mal
appliqué la stratégie ou qu'on avait pas
du tout de
stratégie la stratégie militaire repose
sur le principe de
l'économie économie au sens de
parsimonie au sens où on dit qu'on
économise les forces donc pas de code de
l'honneur pas de vertu guerrière parce
que la guerre n'est pas une affaire de
morale c'est une affaire de
survie la survie est au-dessus de la
morale la survie est au-dessus de tout
sunsou c'est un peu le général qu'aurait
voulu
maavel maavel qui a lui aussi écrit un
ouvrage qui s'appelle l'art de la guerre
et qui sur le plan politique développe
exactement la même approche que sunsu à
savoir que le pouvoir c'est d'abord de
la
stratégie et que le meilleur des
stratèges c'est celui qui met la morale
de
côté c'est celui qui privilégie
l'efficacité rappelez-vous ce que disait
macavel il disait que le prince devait
maîtriser l'art de la simulation et de
la
dissimulation qu'être juste n'était pas
une finalité en soi
qu'il fallait être juste quand c'était
utile mais ne pas hésiter à être injuste
quand c'était plus utile raison pour
laquelle quand on lui demandait s'il
valait mieux être craint ou être aimé
machabelle répondait qu'il valait mieux
être
craint parce qu'on se soumet plus
facilement par crainte que par amour
preuve en est qu'après avoir tué les
deux maîtresses du roi tout le monde a
filé droit on fait pas d'omelette sans
casser des ufs bien de la même façon que
le critère de macavel c'est l'utilité
pour le pouvoir le critère de sunsu
c'est l'utilité pour la victoire et
quand maavel dit que le prince doit
maîtriser l'art de la simulation et de
la dissimulation sunsu dit quant à lui
je cite toute guerre est fondée sur le
semblant sur le semblant c'est-à-dire
sur les
apparences et donc sur la falsification
des
apparences on veut attaquer par l'ouest
on fit mine d'attaquer par
l'est on dispose d'une armée puissante
on fait mine d'être affaibli et
inversement bref on fait tout pour
tromper
l'adversaire pour tromper sa
perception c'est presque du décartte
avant l'heure l'idée que nos perceptions
sont trompeuses et qu'il faut se fier
non pas à sa perception mais à sa raison
donc si vous êtes sur le champ de
bataille et qu'au loin vous apercevez de
la fumée vous allez vous dire les
ennemis sont là ils ont établi leur
campement ils font du feu pour faire
bouillir la marmite et maintenant qu'on
les a localisé on va pouvoir les
encercler et se jeter sur
eux sauf que le temps que vous arriviez
jusqu'à eux c'est vous qui vous êtes
fait encercler parce que le feu avait
été allumé intentionnellement pour vous
attirer jusque
là parce que voyant ce feu vous en avez
déduit que l'ennemi était là et qu'il
fallait y aller mais vous ne vous êtes
pas dit que votre ennemi avait anticipé
cette réaction vous êtes tombé dans son
piège l'art de la guerre n'est donc pas
seulement l'art de la simulation c'est
aussi l'art de l'anticipation
l'anticipation qui dépend justement de
la raison qu'est-ce que la raison sinon
l'outil qui permet d'anticiper ce qui va
arriver à partir de ce qui est c'est la
définition de
l'intelligence
observation compréhension
adaptation l'intelligence c'est une
projection dans la
causalité projection parce que ce n'est
pas encore arrivé dans la causalité
parce que les faits sont déterminé par
la
causalité tout ce qui arrive a des
raisons d'arriver
l'intelligence c'est être capable de
créer des situations dont les
conséquences sont
prévisibles et d'exploiter ces
conséquences à son
avantage la guerre selon sunsu c'est une
partie d'échec
ou de jeu de Go si on veut rester dans
la culture chinoise le jeu de Go c'est
un jeu de stratégie dans lequel
l'objectif c'est de capturer des
territoires en les
encerclant c'est un jeu très complexe
dans lequel le hasard et la
précipitation n'ont pas leur
place de la même façon aux échecs on
réfléchit avant de jouer on projette
mentalement les conséquences à court
moyen et long terme de chaque
déplacement de
pièce il faut anticiper la réponse de
l'adversaire et il faut anticiper sa
réponse à notre réponse un vrai cast
chinois donc les échecs c'est l'une des
meilleures transpositions de l'art de la
guerre parce que c'est une guerre de
prédiction quand un maître d'échec
annonce mat en H coups ça veut dire
qu'il est capable d'anticiper cette
réponse de
l'adversaire parce que c'est ça
l'intelligence la
prédiction la prédiction issue de
l'analyse
abstraite quelqu'un qui agit de manière
imp ulsive quelqu'un qui ne projette pas
par avance les conséquences de son
action c'est quelqu'un qui ne peut pas
l'emporter sur quelqu'un qui anticipe
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc la
recommandation principale de sunsu c'est
que pour gagner une guerre il ne faut
pas combattre
énergiquement il faut combattre
intelligemment donc la guerre ne doit
pas être confiée à des brutes épaisses
elle doit être confi à des gros cerveaux
à des cerveaux insensibles au bien et au
mal mais extrêmement sensible aux
informations l'intelligence c'est la
sensibilité aux
informations quand on lit sunsu on a
l'impression que gagner une guerre il y
a rien de plus simple qu'il suffit de
réfléchir avant d'agir qu'il suffit de
ne pas se lancer aveuglément dans la
bataille et de juste prendre de la
hauteur quelque chose il faut
bienadmettre que nous ne faisons pas
toujours lorsqu'on est en situation de
conflit la plupart du temps on est sous
l'emprise de nos
émotions c'est la colère qui guide notre
comportement c'est le ressentiment c'est
la jalousie c'est le désir de
vengeance dans notre esprit la guerre
est associée à ce que Spinoza appelle
les passions tristes
c'est-à-dire les émotions
négatives ce que nous dit sunsu c'est
qu'aborder un conflit sous le prisme de
l'émotion c'est se condamner à le
perdre parce que les émotions
obscurcissent le jugement et en
obscurcissant le jugement
elles nous font commettre des
erreurs on le fait
tous quand on est en colère contre
quelqu'un nos mots vont dépasser notre
pensée
nos actes vont dépasser notre volonté on
s'emporte et
s'emporter c'est se faire emporter c'est
perdre le contrôle pour ssou la guerre
c'est le contrôle le contrôle de son
armée bien sûr mais aussi le contrôle de
ses émotions les émotions ne sont pas un
terrain propice à la
réflexion ou à
l'anticipation c'est la sérénité qu'il
est le
détachement voyez quand je vous disais
que pour sunsou la guerre éta quelque
chose de Vital ça se perçoit dans la
froideur de son
approche la guerre ça ne sert pas à se
défouler ça ne sert pas à expulser son
énergie pour se sentir
soulagé ça c'est une approche
émotionnelle du conflit l'apoche doit
être rationnelle
et de la même façon que les stoien
disaient que les passions nous
empêchaient d'être libre parce qu'ell
perturb le jugement rationnel de la même
façon sunsu nous dit qu'il ne faut pas
éprouver de colère contre l'ennemi il ne
faut pas le
haïr il faut le
comprendre mettre son ego de côté et se
demander comment pense mon
ennemi parce que dès lors que je
comprends comment pense mon ennemi je
deviens en mesure d'anticiper sa
prochaine action et donc de
l'attaquer ce que je ne peux pas faire
si je suis aveuglé par mes émotions nos
émotions rétrécissent notre champ
attentionnel on se focalise sur nos
émotions et donc on ne voit plus le
reste quand Spinoza dit ne pas déplorer
ne pas maudire mais comprendre il dit la
même chose que sunsu il dit que la
compréhension est plus bénéfique que
l'émotion et que quand on veut combattre
quelqu'un il faut s'efforcer de le
comprendre quand vous vous disputez avec
votre patron ou avec un ami ou avec
votre
conjoint ce qui vous anime ce n'est pas
le désir de comprendre l'autre c'est le
désir de vous affirmer et d'avoir raison
contre votre
interlocuteur ce qui nous anime dans un
conflit c'est le désir de
reconnaissance c'est-à-dire le désir que
l'autre s'incline et reconnaissent que
nous avons
raison c'est ça un conflit géré par
l'ego le seul problème c'est qu'il y a
de grandes chances que la personne en
face de vous se dise la même chose et
dans cette situation plus l'implication
émotionnelle va être forte plus vous
avez de risque de faire un faux par
de dire quelque chose qu'il ne fallait
pas
dire quelque chose qui va vous causer du
tort donc l'art de la guerre repose sur
le détachement
émotionnel sur le désengagement
émotionnel je vais le dire autrement une
guerre c'est pas personnel c'est la
réplique de Michael Corleon dans le
parrain peu avant qu'il commette son
premier assassinat c'est pas personnel
c'est uniquement les
affaires une règle que Michael ne
respectera pas lorsqu'il tuera son frère
Fredo après que celui-ci l'ai trahi
avant de le tuer Michael dira à Fredo tu
m'as brisé le cœur c'était
personnel d'ailleurs vous aurez marqué
que le parrain c'est très long il n'y a
pas énormément
d'action par contre quand il y a de
l'action c'est expéditif
expéditif parce qu'une offensive doit
être
expéditive une guerre doit être la plus
brève possible nous dit
sunsu donc c'est très long parce que le
plus clair du temps on ne le passe pas à
attaquer on le passe à
réfléchir à élaborer une
stratégie la stratégie la plus
maquiavéque qui soit et c'est seulement
une fois que la stratégie est bien
définie passe à
l'action alors il se trouve que l'art de
la guerre est un livre particulièrement
apprécié dans le monde de l'économie et
de la finance et que vous dira un
investisseur il vous dira que le plus
souvent ne pas investir c'est gagner de
l'argent ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que le désir d'investir doit être régulé
par l'intérêt à investir on ninvestit
pas s'il n'y a pas intérêt à
investir il vaut mieux
attendre donc attendre ça fait partie de
la
stratégie de la stratégie
gagnante donc dire que ne pas investir
nous fait gagner de l'argent c'est dire
qu'une erreur est toujours un manque à
gagner et qu'il faut accepter parfois de
patienter la patience étant précisément
la marque d'une maîtrise de ces
émotions et d'ailleurs c'est amusant que
le mot investir face à la fois partie du
lexique de la finance et du lexique
militaire investir de l'argent investir
un
territoire on parlait du parrain et du
fait qu'on trouvait dans le parrain
certaines allusions à l'art de la guerre
de sunsu il y en a une autre encore plus
connue qui est garde tes amis près de
toi et tes ennemis encore plus près
c'est une phrase que prononce Michael
dans le Parin 2 et c'est une reprise
directe d'une phrase de sunsu qui dit
connais-toi toi-même et connais ton
ennemi donc connais-toi toi-même on
pense évidemment à Socrate et connait
ton ennemi benah on pense à
sphinoa ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure ne pas maudire mais comprendre
connais ton ennemi c'est vraiment ça
la règle d'or de l'art de la guerre s'il
n en avait qu'une à retenir ce serait
celle-là parce qu'elle contient toutes
les autres
elle contient l'idée que la connaissance
est plus utile que la force elle
contient l'idée qu'il faut privilégier
la raison aux émotions et elle contient
l'idée que la guerre n'est pas une
affaire
d'ego et que donc il faut être capable
de se transposer dans la conscience de
l'ennemi
de voir comme lui de penser comme lui
quand on tend un piège à l'ennemi il
faut se mettre à sa
place c'est-à-dire oublier notre propre
pensée et notre propre
perception aussi paradoxal que ça puisse
être l'art de la guerre repose sur
l'empathie une empathie instrumentale
une empathie
stratégique mais une empathie tout de
même quelqu'un qui crée une entreprise
ou quelqu'un qui crée un produit ce
qu'on lui apprend dans les écoles de
commerce c'est de ne pas penser en
créateur c'est de penser en
consommur c'est de mettre à la place de
son
client le client est en celui dont il
faut investir le
porteuille mettre à la place du client
ça veut dire décentrer son point de vue
se focaliser sur la conscience de
l'autre plutôt que sur sa propre
conscience
parce que la conscience de l'autre
détermine son comportement et que son
comportement détermine le
nôre je disais tout à l'heure que quand
on pensait à la guerre on pensait
immédiatement à la
force en l'occurrence à la force
matérielle les armes les soldats
l'équipement mais il y a un deuxième
type de force auquel on doit également
penser c'est la force
mentale le fameux moral des troupes et
dans une guerre on se doit de tenir
compte du moral des
troupes du moral de ces troupes et du
moral des troupes
adverses que nous dit
sunsu il nous dit que le facteur
psychologique est un élément déterminant
de l'équation militaire on l'a dit tout
à l'heure l'art de la guerre c'est l'art
de la
tromperie donc la manipulation
psychologique fait partie de la
stratégie toujours selon l'idée que le
critère c'est
l'efficacité donc il faut ménager le
moral de ces troupes et il faut
atteindre le moral des troupes adverses
et ça ça nous ramène directement à
quelque chose qui est énormément
exploité depuis le 20e siècle à savoir
la propagande de guerre en temps de
guerre l'information n'est pas neutre
elle ne peut pas être neutre
parce que l'information fait partie de
la
stratégie le but de la propagande de
guerre c'est de mettre l'opinion
publique dans sa
poche pour que les soldats se sentent
soutenus pour qu'à leur retour il soi
accueillis comme des héros pas comme des
bouchés et aussi pour que le
gouvernement a les mains libres pour
agir pour débloquer les budgets pour
justifier un effort national
le fameux effort
national donc la guerre contemporaine
est à la fois opérationnelle et
informationnelle et la désinformation se
confond avec
l'information il n'y a plus
d'information vraie ou d'information
fausse il y a de l'information utile
ou de l'information
nuisible et ce n'est pas propre à un
état ou à un autre
c'est propre à tout État qui s'engage
dans un conflit
ou qui a des intérêts dans ce
conflit parce que la guerre est une
affaire
d'intérêt donc la propagande de guerre
c'est tout ce qui consiste à introduire
dans le commentaire des opérations
militaires des informations fausses ou
incomplètes qui justifieront le
déploiement de moyens
supplémentaires plus l'ennemi sera
présenté comme dangereux comme sang aire
comme imprévisible plus l'opinion va
trouver logique et légitime qu'on recour
à tous les moyens disponibles contre lui
le principe de la propagande c'est le
manquéisme c'est la diabolisation de
l'ennemi parce que la nuance est
interdite en tant de
guerre la vérité est
interdite comme le disait Noam schomski
le but de la propagande c'est la
fabrique du
dès lors que vous vous prononcez sur un
conflit dès lors que vous vous prononcez
sur qui a tort ou qui a raison sur la
base des informations émanant de
l'appareil médiatique de l'État auquel
vous appartenez vous devenez un relais
de cette
propagande un élément des forces
psychologiques engagé dans le
conflit que vous le vouliez ou
non et encore une fois le propos n'est
pas de savoir si c'est bien ou si c'est
mal le propos est de savoir est-ce que
c'est
efficace oui c'est efficace et pour ssou
tout ce qui est efficace doit être
mobilisé donc bien sûr à son époque il
n'y avait pas de propagande de guerre
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de moyens de
communication à grande échelle mais le
principe reste le même la
désinformation la
manipulation au profit de l'intérêt
supérieur de la
nation
savez-vous comment on appelle le fait
d'entretenir des relations secrètes avec
un ennemi en temps de guerre on appelle
ça intelligence avec
l'ennemi pas
connivance pas
complicité
intelligence à croire que même au niveau
de la désignation juridique
l'intelligence va de pad avec la
malfaisance dans le myth de proméé
l'intelligence est symbolisée par le
feu parce que le feu c'est une source de
lumière et que plus on a de lumière plus
on peut voir loin
l'intelligence c'est la capacité à voir
loin
avoir l'enchaînement des
étapes l'intelligence est ce qui rend
prévoyant on voit avant avant quoi avant
d'agir
on voit les conséquences déclenchées par
notre action avant que cette action nit
eu lieu en grec prometé veut dire le
prévoyant c'est lui que les dieux ont
désigné pour créer les animaux sur terre
et mal avisé pour le coup il laisse son
frère épimété s'en occuper à sa place
épimété se met au travail il répartit
les forces et les faiblesses certains
auront des plumes
d'autres des poils certains auront des
cornes d'autres des griffes il fait ça
très bien sauf qu'il oublie l'homme
l'homme se retrouve
nu nu donc
désemparé à la merci des autres
espèces pour corriger le tir promettez
va dérober le feu sacré de l'Olympe pour
le donner aux
hommes muni du feu les hommes deviennent
intelligents ils deviennent
éclairés et depuis l'homme sé au sommet
de la chaîne
alimentaire l'origine du pouvoir de
l'homme c'est son
esprit un esprit qu'il peut prolonger
dans la matière par l'intermédiaire de
ses mains sans l'intelligence l'homme
aurait déjà
disparu il se pourrait d'ailleurs
d'illeurs qu'il disparaisse à cause de
son
intelligence mais c'est une autre
histoire tout ça pour dire que ce qu'à
compris sunsu c'est le primat de
l'esprit sur la
matière c'est le fait que quand une armé
triomp c'est son intelligence qui
triomp
l'intelligence c'est la manipulation
spirituelle des forces
matérielles dans l'épisode biblique du
jardin d'Eden le serpent parvient à
convaincre Ève puis Adam de goûter le
fruit défendu qu'a-t-il fait pour les
convaincre il les a séduit il leur a dit
si vous goûtez ce fruit vos yeux
s'ouvriront et vous serez comme Dieu
vous connaîtrez le bien et le
mal ça donne
envie surtout quand on a aucune idée de
ce qu'est la distinction entre le bien
et le
mal avec cette stratégie le serpent
était sûr d'arriver à ses fins parce
qu'il a donné à Adam et Ève une
motivation à enfreindre
l'interdit il ne les a pas forcé il ne
les a pas contraints il les a
séduit et si le serpent est bel et bien
Satan ou l'un de ses disciples on
comprend en quoi la séduction constitue
la stratégie du
mal Satan a comme surnom le
tentateur et étymologiquement séduire ça
veut dire
dévier ça veut dire
détourner détourner du bien et du droit
chemin l'être humain est corruptible et
ce qui le rend
corruptible ce sont ses
passions ce sont ses
désirs l'être humain possède le désir et
Satan c'est celui qui tire les ficelles
de notre
désir pour nous amener à commettre le
péché le péché étant ce qui nous liit à
la
matière Satan a besoin de montrer à Dieu
que l'être humain est
ville qu'il est littéralement
indigne Satan a refusé de se prosterner
devant Adam comme Dieu le lui avait
demandé il a refusé de se prosterner
devant un être indigne et c'est la
raison pour laquelle Dieu l'a
déchu Satan était un ange il est tenu un
démon un ange
maléfique pour n'avoir pas voulu
reconnaître la grandeur de
l'homme satan s'est alors donné une
mission prouver à Dieu qu'il a eu
tort prouver à Dieu que l'homme est
mauvais et qu' ne mérite pas le respect
des anges d lors Satan va dédier son
existence à détourner l'homme du
bien à le faire tomber c'est l'image de
la chute dans ce qu'il y a de plus vil
et de plus sombre en
lui quand l'homme commet le mal Satan
rit parce qu'il sait que le mal condamne
les hommes il les condamne à la
souffrance il les condamne à la mort et
à la
répétition
Satan est le maître du monde parce que
le monde est gouverné par le
désir le monde est gouverné par le
chaos dans la tradition chrétienne Satan
est parfois associé à un autre nom sans
qu'il soit possible de savoir s'il
s'agit exactement de la même
entité
Lucifer Lucifer ça veut dire
littéralement le porteur de lumière on
l'a vu avec prometté la lumière c'est
l'intelligence et Lucifer est
intelligent le mal est
intelligent
l'intelligence c'est ce qui permet au
mal de nous conduire là où nous n'avions
pas prévu
d'aller de nous
manipuler de nous
téléguider le mal ne nous touche pas il
ne pose pas sa main sur nous il nous
attire il nous dit viens avec sa
main le mal ne nous force pas il nous
met en
confiance c'est comme ça qu'il nous
séduit jusqu'au moment où on se retrouve
pris dans sa
toile
piégé piégé par
nous-même en d'autres termes le mal nous
connaît il est obligé de nous connaître
pour se jouer de
nous il connaît nos
faiblesses il sait ce qui est en nous
mieux que
nous-mêmes le mal opère par la
suggestion c'est-à-dire en amenant sa
proie à agir
volontairement et en s'appuyant sur
notre nature pour faire de nous ce qu'il
veut c'est ça l'intelligence
maléfique
l'intelligence qui nous connaît et qui
utilise sa connaissance de ce que nous
sommes
pour parvenir à ses
fins moralité la chose la plus
dangereuse au monde la chose la plus à
craindre au monde le mal ne triomp pas
par la force il triomp par la
connaissance et par
l'intelligence
l'intelligence c'est la véritable
force car elle est la puissance de
l'Esprit et que l'esprit est capable de
tout le point commun entre Satan et
sunsu c'est d'avoir compris ça c'est
d'avoir compris que la connaissance de
l'adversaire rendait possible la
victoire contre
l'adversaire et que quand on utilise
l'intelligence le combat devient
superflu je
cite la guerre est d'une importance
vitale pour l'État c'est le domaine de
la vie et de la mort la obervation ou la
perte de l'Empire en dépendent il est
impérieux de bien le régler ne pas faire
de sérieuses réflexions sur ce qui le
concerne c'est faire preuve d'une
coupable indifférence pour la
conservation ou pour la perte de ce
qu'on a de plus cher et c'est ce qu'on
doit pas trouver parmi nous toute
campagne guerrière doit être réglé sur
le semblant feignez le désordre ne
manquez jamais d'offrir un appâ à
l'ennemi pour le leurer simuler
l'infériorité pour encourager son
arrogance sachez attiser son courou pour
mieux le plonger dans la confusion sa
convoi le lancera sur vous pour s'y
briser attez vos préparatifs lorsque vos
adversaires se concentrent là où ils
sont puissants évitez-les plongez
l'adversaire dans d'inextricables
épreuves et prolonger son épuisement en
vous tenant à distance veillez à
fortifier vos alliances au- dehors et
affermir vos positions au-dedans par une
politique de soldat paysan quel regret
que de tout risquer en un seul combat en
négligeant la stratégie victorieuse et
faire dépendre le sort de vos armes
d'une unique bataille lorsque est uni
divisez-le et attaquez là où il n'est
point préparé en surgissant lorsqu'il ne
vous attend point telleles sont les clés
stratégiques de la victoire quand vous
êtes capable feignez l'incapacité quand
vous agissez feignez l'inactivité quand
vous êtes proche feignez l'éloignement
quand vous êtes loin feignez la
proximité connais ton ennemi et
connais-toi toi-même eussiez-vous sans
guerre à soutenir 100 fois vous serez
victorieux si tu ignores ton ennemi et
que tu te connais toi-même tes chances
de perdre et de gagner seront égales si
tu ignores à la fois ton ennemi et
toi-même tu ne compteas tes combats que
par tes défaites l'art de profiter du
près et du loin consiste à tenir
l'ennemi éloigné du lieu que vous aurez
choisi pour votre campement et de tous
les postes qui vous paraîtront de
quelques conséquences ils consiste à
éloigner de l'ennemi tout ce qui
pourrait lui être avantageux et à
rapprocher de vous tout ce dont vous
pourrez tirer quelque avantage il
consiste ensuite à vous tenir
continuellement sur vos gardes pour
n'être pas surpris et à veiller est sans
cesse pouré pied le moment de surprendre
votre adversaire aussi prenez une voix
indirecte et divertissez l'ennemi en lui
présentant le leure de cette façon vous
pouvez vous mettre en route après lui et
arriver avant lui celui qui est capable
de faire cela comprend l'approche direct
et indirect avant que d'en venir à un
combat définitif il faut que vous l'ayez
prévu et que vous y soyez préparé depuis
longtemps ne comptez jamais sur le
hasard dans tout ce que vous devez faire
en ce genre n'agissez pas si vous ne
voyez pas d'intérêt clair pour le pays
n'utilisez pas vos soldats si vous
n'êtes pas sûr du succès ne combattez
pas si vous n'êtes pas menacé un
souverain n'ordonne pas à son général de
lever une armée sous le coup de la
colère un général n'attaque pas parce
qu'on lui a fait affront lorsqu'un
souverain est animé par la colère ou par
la vengeance qu'il ne lui arrive jamais
de lever des troupes lorsqu'un général
trouve qu'il a dans le cœur les mêmes
sentiments qu'il ne livre jamais de
combat pour l'un et pour l'autre ce sont
des temps nébuleux qu'ils attendent les
jours de sérénité pour se déterminer et
pour
entreprendre la guerre ce ne sont pas
seulement les théâtres
d'opération ce ne sont pas seulement les
missiles et les
bombes la guerre c'est aussi la guerre
économique la guerre
sociale la guerre d'é
Goos il y a guerre quand il y a
recherche du pouvoir et ce pouvoir peut
aussi bien prendre
la forme d'intérêt matériel que
d'intérêt
symbolique on est en guerre contre celui
qui ne nous reconnaît pas qui ne
reconnaît pas notre
importance notre valeur en est en guerre
contre ses proches quand on veut leur
imposer notre vision des choses
ou quand les écouter n'est plus qu'un
prétexte pour les
réfuter on est en guerre dès lors qu'il
y a besoin de
prouver et il est parfois nécessaire de
mener certaines
guerres parce que dès lors qu'on vit en
société il faut savoir
s'affirmer il faut savoir se
confronter tout le monde n'est pas animé
par des intentions pures et ne pas
réagir rester passif face à ça passif
Pacifique
c'est oublier que la survie a ses
impératifs mais une fois qu'on a admis
que certaines guerres étaient
nécessaires n'est-il pas vrai que nous
avons aussi tendance à alimenter des
guerres
inutiles à concevoir notre existence
comme un vaste champ de bataille et
notre prochain comme un
ennemi se pourrait-il que notre besoin
de conflit déborde sur des cibles qu' ne
mérite
pas se pourrait-il que notre besoin de
conflit se retourne contre nous-mêmes au
quel cas on retomberait sur cette
recommandation de sunsu qui est que l'on
a tout à gagner à choisir ses
combats je vous
[Musique]
remercie